ob kumpelhaft
oder als domina hinter der verkleidung
steckt immer dieselbe frau
die tschechische fotograf in die tapete
interessiert sich nicht bloß für andere
menschen
sie wird auf ihren fotos zu deren
ebenbild
ein anderes haus eine andere hautfarbe
letztlich steckt das leben voller zufall
dass die suche nach diesem ideal für die
fotografen auch zu exzentrischen figur
wie zu musiker edgar und seiner freundin
barbara
hier kann sie nach belieben mit rollen
experimentell
die der heute ist dass ich jung bin
immer noch auch vielleicht eine sängerin
sein kann
mit dem zusammen in eine gruppe spiel
bekam ich kann motor sein von barbara
oder schwester vor dem von edgar also
ich weiß nicht genau was für eine rolle
aber ich denke ich kann noch einen teil
von deren leben sein
kleine fluchten aus dem begrenzten leben
sowie schon als kleines mädchen als sie
sich mit perücke und hut wie eine
schauspielerin gefühlt hatte ihr
patriarchalischer vater habe ihr nicht
viel entwicklungsraum zugestanden
so entstand die idee mit den
selbstportraits an der seite von frauen
um ihre möglichen rollen in einer
beziehung zu erkunden
ich habe das richtig markt die die der
mann gegen entstehen kann und trotzdem
mit ihm zusammen ja so und ihr habt von
jede frau habe ich mir was was
ausgesucht was für mein leben sehr
wichtig war
später erweiterte sie den fotografischen
blick auf männer stellte sich an deren
seite um herauszufinden was ein gutes
leben ausmacht für mich selbst ist das
eine art therapie weil ich selbst
dadurch was für mich wichtig ist was ich
würde mich unwichtig oder was ist für
mich schön was ich gern machen konnte
wenn ich das wusste weil ganz viele
sachen weiß ich immer noch nicht
wie wäre etwa ein leben als frau in
einer roma sippel oder in einer
patchworkfamilie
auch ihre beiden töchter sind von klein
an teil der fotos mit neu arrangierten
familie
ein rollenwechsel manchmal schon nur
durch eine andere position
oder mini
schwester mutter oder gar
konkurrentinnen um denselben mann
parallelen zum eigenen leben finden sich
über reiben so stellt sie in ihrem
neuesten projekt patíz von frauen mit
schwierigen lebensgeschichten neben ihre
selbstporträts
all das um rollen und identität zu
hinterfragen kennt sie in ihrer arbeit
überhaupt grenzen es gibt grenzen weil
ich bin eine mutter ich bin eine tochter
und ich für mich immer sehr wichtig und
da da weiß ich dass das selbst nicht gut
ist für mich dass es würde mich sehr
wichtig ist dass die leute mich mögen
dass die leute sagen dies gut dass ich
will die leute nicht enttäuschen ich
will nicht mein mann enttäuschen ich
will nicht meine kinder enttäuschen ich
will nicht meine mutter enttäuschen und
es gibt dann grenzen obwohl ich sehr
interessiert bin
die grenze überschreiten
ein foto zeigt die wahre dieter bibel
umringt von mann und kindern befremdlich
normal in der ganzen serie aber für den
betrachter so etwas wie das bild einer
idealen familie